yeah I was I told you I saw that Vlad
interview last year did you and the baby
ever work out whatever you guys had
going on internet it was just like some
comments getting left yeah yeah yeah
it's just you know he was mad in my
comments but I mean I mean at the end of
the day you try to stay out the media
you're giving your uh you were given
your uh opinion on how you felt about
certain [__] yeah you know it is what it
is people can feel it I mean I just had
estg walk out of an interview because I
asked them about yes label so I saw that
bro yeah you haven't walked out yet no
no you cool you I appreciate it you
ain't asked me no weird
uh man talk to me about just Chicago bro
because obviously you know there's been
so much uh I mean [__] man Dirk has a
headline in Arena tour right now
um I was just there oh in Chicago yeah
that's where I just came from now I
opened up the first day was Were You
There When the shooting had happened and
the that was the day
um after the day you weren't at that
show no I wasn't there okay uh the the
crew was there though some of the guys
was there but I went there but um the
first day was was cool I don't think it
was no shooting though I think that's
cap though I don't know I just know that
there was this video yeah I know I know
some folks was fighting and somebody
might have got cut or stabbed or
something I don't think it was no
shooting I just saw the video everyone
running and then everyone just grabbing
merch yeah yeah see there's a lot of
that going on because the show ended
early yeah so I think the fans was upset
for real or something you know was was
Kodak on that show
I don't know who was that who was there
that day I feel like kodak's on that
tour you toured with Kodak right what
was that like
um when Kodak was fun he seems like a
fun hang yeah he was cool he was real
cool
yeah he seems like the kind of guy who
I'd like to have a beer with
that's it though that's it nothing else
I don't know what else he'd be doing I
just met just take the beer man I was
around Kodak when we was doing shows you
know what I'm saying um he hopped on my
two of us a few times I wanted to record
I had to look portable uh studio with me
during the setup yeah so I recorded a
song form
would you have to drive like the Scarlet
little Scarlet like interface I had the
uh Apollo Arrow the Apollo yeah yeah
yeah I hit the Apollo Arrow
um
yeah we just vibed the whole time it was
like 40 something shows as I say like
from when you kind of popped and
initially the now where how do you feel
about like kind of the state of Chicago
hip-hop
it's pretty cool a lot of females is
turning up in our city right now
um
but it's cool right now I had a young
lady from Chicago here who was it
we just had somebody here from Chicago
it's a girl oh mellow
no
who the [__] was just here fancy Fendi
Fendi yep yeah she's great
yeah she's uh she's she's super cool
who's mellow mellow rocks is she from uh
no not Miller racks mellow bucks okay
okay because there's no rack so I think
racks from like Miami or something yeah
yeah because she's on a YMC and B I
think